what about you did you read this when
you were younger I didn't I I read a lot
of Judy's stuff I love the fudge series
I read a lot of her books when I was
younger but I I hadn't read Margaret I
was like oh this is about boobs and
things like and I think I was seven when
it came on my radar you know all my
friends older sisters who were like 10
were reading it and yeah like oh one day
I didn't realize it would be like 40
when that one day came and I'd be
playing Margaret's mom you know I mean
that just still blows my mind thank you
so much yeah
um so pop culture thing yeah it really
is so when I did finally read it for the
film uh you know I there were so many
great nuggets for my character in there
and it was great to read it as a mom
about to play this mom but what I also
loved was that I related so much to
Margaret you know I was like oh I see
why this is such a Timeless story
um I just went right back to my
childhood and all the feels and
um and yeah it just really packed a
punch
yeah a lot of things change in life not
puberty nope just sucks at any
Generation Um it's just hard but you've
played moms before but now you're a mom
playing a mom was that different for you
yeah I think I was more relaxed about it
I was always the more pressure when you
didn't have kids I didn't have kids and
I was playing Moms I was like I'm
missing something I'm sure of it
um you know it's like your idea of being
a mom is so different from the real
thing so yeah I think I I didn't
um do as much Mom research yeah well I
think when you figure out your mom no
one's got it figured out so right
exactly yeah it's a crap shoot just get
out there and try try your best go for
that green participation ribbon
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]